my parents were both rate my mom was
raised Quaker and my dad was raised
Anglican and Baptist it's like a very
complicated story my-my dad's maternal
grandfather was from Nazareth as we all
know Jesus is from Nazareth but he went
to Waco Texas became a Baptist minister
and then moved back to Nazareth and
founded a Baptist Church in Nazareth so
my grandmother was raised Baptist and my
grandfather my father's father was
raised Anglican because it was an
English colony so Palestine was so that
was my one side and my mother's side her
her father had converted to Quaker which
is completely random I think there's
only two or three Quaker families in
Lebanon to this day so I was I'm a
minority within a minority in terms of
the Arab world and I never understood
what that meant so both of my parents
were raised with all of this tradition
and both the schools I went to were
Episcopal so I had learned a lot of the
Bible verses and the Lord's Prayer so I
was raised in effect as a Christian in
the way that many of us are in this
country sort of a secular Christian like
we celebrate Christmas and Easter we eat
eggs and but there wasn't a lot of talk
of the Bible except as a work of
literature and then uh growing up I you
know I would cling to being Christian
because it would make me ending me a
little bit more like other people that I
knew and it's funny as a I don't I only
identify as a Christian Arab when people
assume that I'm Muslim for some reason
it makes me annoyed and that's part of
the whole struggle which is you know
part of the reason probably that Muslims
insists that they're Muslims because
they're feeling they feel threatened so
for me there's been a lot caught up in
in especially like the Palestinian
struggle having become or very clearly
viewed as a Muslim thing or an Islamic
thing or that makes me very frustrated
the way I was raised this is with
humanism so all people are equal and I
was never taught is it Jewish people
were this and Christian people were that
and Muslims were that I was just it
never occurred to me you know I never no
one in my family was anti-semitic nobody
we didn't talk about people ironically
for for especially being eleven eight
part Lebanese we didn't talk about
people in terms of their religion people
were people and so I think that's great
it's how I've been able to not say you
know Jewish people this Jewish people
that I don't make generalizations like
that I believe that every experience you
have is is an experience so every human
being gives you the opportunity to know
them as a human being and so conversely
every person who knows me and likes me
will know me and like me because of me
oh and I happen to be a Palestinian so
it's hard because also my father passed
away and so when you really realized my
religion is created because you know you
want I miss my dad and I want him to be
up there on a cloud looking after me so
there are times where I feel like I'm so
ingrained in me to believe in
Christianity or heaven but on the other
hand like I think I think the essence of
every single religion is to treat other
people with respect and and kindness
and I think that it's a shame that we've
gotten so far from that because I think
no matter what you believe I think some
of the traditions and beliefs of Judaism
are beautiful same with Islam same with
Christian I they're all fascinating and
of course all the other millions of
religions in the world there are
elements that I find beautiful I just
it's frustrating it's frustrating as
everyone knows to start pigeonholing
everyone into little boxes so I while I
feel like traditionally I was raised
with a very Christian in general
Christian outlook
I really really try to maintain a
humanist perspective and just each
person who interacts with me is a human
being and they are the sum of all of the
things that they represent you know that
their country their religion their you
know their mother's hair color whatever
it is they represent many many different
things not one and I think the biggest
mistake is when we start identifying by
religion so it's tricky but um I mean
I'd love to believe there was a God so
that I can have someone looking out for
me but at the same time and then I can
see my dad again
in heaven when I die but at the same
time like do I really believe I don't
know